[GOOGLE JINGLE]
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC:
Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Google I/O. I'm Vlad.
I'm the lead product manager
for the Google Assistant
for the next billion users.
I must tell you, this is a
hugely rewarding project.
Day-to-day, we get to see
how the Google Assistant is
improving the lives of the
users in emerging countries
by giving them easy and
intuitive access to information
and helping them
getting things done.
Our team is super
passionate about building
the right product to
empower these users
and give them confidence and
independence using technology
through the Google Assistant.
SACHIT MISHRA: Hey, I'm Sachit.
I work on developer relations
for the Google Assistant.
So I've been working
on this product
consistently for the
last three years,
and it's because I
believe in the power
of intelligent experiences and
new paradigms of computing.
These innovations are going
to empower and transform
the lives of the
next billion users.
Building for these
regions, it's an issue
that's close to my heart.
While I've been
working here, I've
had the privilege of
traveling to regions where
the next billion internet
users are coming online,
like Brazil and India.
And I've witnessed firsthand
the extraordinary courage
that developers in those
regions are showing
in betting on new
technologies to serve
their local communities.
And also, specifically as
an Indian American, someone
who has strong roots
in a foreign culture
and has had the privilege
of spending much of my life
with family in
other countries, I
care about bringing Google's
best technology to everyone.
And I think, based on
what you see here today,
you will agree with me--
Actions on Google is the
perfect way to do that.
VLADIMIR VUSKOVIC: OK, first of
all, what is Actions on Google?
So let's start with
the Google Assistant.
The Google Assistant
is a conversation
between you and
Google to help you
get more done in your world.
It works on a variety of
voice-enabled home devices
and on the vast majority
of mobile phones.
Now, Actions on
Google is the platform
that enables you developers to
build your apps for the Google
Assistant.
Today, there are more or
less 7 and 1/2 billion people
in the world.
And only slightly
more than half of them
are connected to the internet.
So 3.5 billion people
are not connected yet.
Now, as the connectivity
grows and the prices
of the connected
mobile phones go down,
more and more of these
people are getting connected
and are coming online.
The talk today is
about two things.
First, it is about
why Actions on Google
is a great way to
build for these users.
And secondly, we'll
get into some details
and give you some tips about
how you can build for them.
Let us see now why
Actions on Google
is a really good way to build
for the new users coming online
for the first time.
So the new users are
going to be different.
They're going to be less urban
and more peri-urban and rural.
They will be less fluent in
English, have a lower income.
They will be very diverse
in terms of age and gender.
But more importantly
for developers,
they will have vastly
different digital habits.
So they have much less
pre-established ways
of how to use technology,
internet, and how
they access information.
They don't have the
legacy of many, many years
of using the internet
first on computers,
then after that on
smartphones, and seeing it
evolve, like many of us here.
They are basically thrown
into a new digital world
without much
pre-existing knowledge.
And they're very likely
to leapfrog the ways
that we use technology.
Now, we are seeing
that the voice user
interface is resonating really,
really well with these users.
And this shouldn't
be a surprise.
Voice is the most
intuitive and, you can say,
most natural human interface.
There is no need
to read manuals.
You just speak and
ask what you want,
almost like you would
do with a friend.
Everybody knows how to do it.
In fact, in the countries where
many users are coming online,
we are seeing that
the Google Assistant
with its voice-first,
very intuitive
user interface is being
adopted very rapidly.
In fact, in countries like
India, Brazil, Indonesia,
and Mexico, the number of active
users of the Google Assistant
grew seven times last year.
These new users are
also different in terms
of the devices they use.
They use Android devices, which
have huge adoption everywhere.
But also recently, very popular
is the Android Go addition.
This is an optimized
version of Android
developed from the ground up
for devices with 1 Gig or less
of RAM and designed to still
offer a snappy and great user
experience also on these
entry-level smartphones.
This platform is
growing very fast.
And today, roughly 70% of
entry-level Android devices
are activating with Go.
Big OAMs, like Nokia,
Motorola, Samsung, Xiaomi,
all have already launched
devices with Android Go.
These new internet users also
use a new nascent category
of smart feature phones.
These are phones with less
memory, less resources.
They have no touchscreen.
But they are fully
connected to the internet.
These phones are available
at a lower price point.
And they're also seeing
a great adoption,
with millions of
users using them
to get to the internet
for the first time.
Now, for these phones that
don't have a modern touchscreen,
the voice interface makes
an even bigger difference
to get things done.
This is even more true for
many languages for which it's
really, really hard to
type on a T9 keyboard,
like, for example, Hindi
and other Indian languages.
So these new devices really
are voice-first, we can tell.
So actually, Google
allows you to leverage
the voice interface of the
Google Assistant for your apps.
We talked a lot about how
voice is a very effective way
for the users in
these emerging markets
to use their phone
technology and internet.
However, implementing voice
is really, really hard.
And there is a reason that
it's only recently getting
a large adoption.
And the reason is
that, basically, only
in recent years, we have all
the right technological pieces
to actually do it well.
Let us give a quick look
into some of the things
that we need to get right.
So speech recognition,
let us start there.
So here, we need to
basically understand,
what is the user pronouncing?
We need to reliably
transform speech into text.
And we have done
huge progress there.
So to measure the accuracy
of speech recognition,
we use a metric that is
called word error rate.
This metric basically
tells us out of 100 words
that we recognize, how
many did we get wrong?
So just some years back,
2013, for American English,
word error rate was 23%.
This basically means that
out of every four words,
we would misrecognize one.
And this makes it
then really difficult
then to understand what is
user actually trying to say.
We've done a lot of
progress since then.
So 2018-- 2015, I'm sorry--
the metric word
error rate was at 8%.
And today, for American
English, it is below 5%.
This means, basically,
out of 20 words,
we recognize correctly
more than 19.
So this is really
a huge difference.
And we are working
hard all the time
to improve speech recognition
across all languages.
We notice that when people
start talking to their devices,
something really
interesting happens.
So something switches, and
somehow naturally they start--
even if it's just devices--
talking to the devices in
a very conversational way.
So instead of "weather Delhi,"
like many people would usually
ask Google, they start
saying things like, "Hey,
could you please let me know
what is the weather going
to be in Delhi like tomorrow?"
It gets even more difficult
since human conversation
is heavily based on context.
But when people talk
to devices, they also
refer to what has been said
previously in dialogue,
what is around them.
And all of this
makes it really hard
for us to actually understand
the meaning behind the words
that the user is saying,
basically to understand
the intent of the user.
Lastly, languages--
to be really helpful,
we need to speak the languages
that the users actually speak.
And we need to understand
what the user is
saying across a variety
of languages and accents.
And the Google Assistant today
is a real language multitalent
and speaks now
nearly 30 languages.
All this is possible because
of some unique strengths
that Google has in
voice, in particular,
in the fields like deep
learning, natural language
understanding, and
understanding user context.
So by using Actions
on Google, again,
you can leverage its
expertise for your apps.
Continuing on languages,
Actions on Google
is now available in many of
the Google Assistant languages,
including some of the
top languages spoken
in the countries where most
people are coming online today.
And again, we always
work to extend the list
of the supported languages.
Let me summarize why
Actions on Google
is a great way to build
for the next billion users
coming online.
So with one implementation,
you reach a diverse set
of users across
different devices.
Not only you reach
all of these users,
but you reach them in a way
that resonates with them
through the voice interface.
And you leverage
the Google expertise
on speech, dialogue,
and languages.
Let us now look at some
awesome developers.
I'll very quickly introduce
some nice examples
to illustrate some
opportunities in some verticals,
like education, hyperlocal
information, health, and games.
Hello English is a highly
successful language learning
mobile app and has
created a fantastic Action
available in English and Hindi.
The Action has a persona
called Madhu Sharma that
helps the users learn English.
This Action has been
very successful.
And it illustrates the hunger
of these users to learn
and better themselves
and the opportunities,
the huge opportunities
in education vertical.
Where Is My Train is a super
handy utility for tracking
trains across the extensive
rail network in India,
with millions installed
in Google Play.
With Actions on
Google, it enables
users to check their train
just using their voice.
So, for example,
they can say, "Ask
Where Is My Train to locate
the Hyderabad express."
This example shows
how Actions providing
hyperlocal relevant information
can be very relevant to users
and provide real
value to their lives.
Colgate Kids is a
very nice Action
launched in Brazilian
Portuguese that teaches kids
how to wash their teeth properly
with explanation and the music
of the right duration.
It's an example of the
opportunities in the health
vertical.
Galinha Pintadinha have a super
successful YouTube channel.
Their Action in
Brazilian Portuguese
allows kids to get in touch
with their favorite character.
They can talk to Galinha,
and she'll answer
with her already famous voice.
They can play games like
memory, or recognize characters
from the shadows, or listen to
Galinha's most famous songs.
It shows the opportunities
in the games vertical.
Another great game
example is Chhota Bheem.
Chhota Bheem is a very popular
kids character in India.
For the launch of their latest
movie "Chhota Bheem Kung Fu
Dhamaka," they have
built a personality quiz
where kids can answer a series
of questions in the movie
universe.
I'll close my short
list of examples
with Cricbuzz, which
is the go-to platform
to consume
cricket-related content.
Cricbuzz launched an Action
on Google using templates.
This action is a
nice example of how
you can implement high-quality
experiences super quickly
by just using templates.
Let us now talk about what
makes these experiences
great for users and how
you can build for them.
SACHIT MISHRA: All right,
so we've seen some great use
cases here that
have demonstrably
proven real value in the lives
of users in these markets.
And clearly, there is an
immense opportunity here.
But let's talk about actually
getting our hands dirty
and building for these users.
So the first thing to consider
is the client devices.
So what are they actually
holding in their hands?
Well, in many of
these regions, users
can buy Google Homes or other
Assistant-enabled third-party
smart speaker devices.
These are designed for the
assistive experience at home.
They are stationary, and
they're always ready to help.
This has dedicated hardware.
And it's usually a shared device
commonly used by families.
Now, in the mobile world,
first and foremost is Android.
So Assistant already
has a huge presence
on the well-established
Android ecosystem.
And this is the full
intermodal assistant
and Actions on Google
experience without limitations.
So users on these
devices, they tend
to be more experienced
with mobile and internet
technologies.
And with this hardware,
they might already
be your customer on another
platform, like Google Play.
And also common in these regions
are our Android Go devices.
So Android Go edition is an
optimized version of Android.
It was launched in 2017.
And it's built for devices
with 1 gigabyte or less of RAM.
So it comes with a suite
of optimized Google Apps,
including the Google Assistant.
And this allows more users to
join the Android ecosystem.
So the great news here is that
your Actions will be available
on these devices soon with
no extra work on your part.
Now, this brings us to some of
the cheapest devices running
Google Assistant.
These are smart feature phones.
So these are extremely
affordable devices.
They're as low as 20 US dollars.
And they run a light
operating system called KaiOS.
Now, they may remind you
of some of our handsets,
the most premier handsets
from 15 or 20 years ago.
But these phones
can do so much more.
They are Wi-Fi and 4G-enabled.
And they're often sold
with generous data
plans that can prorate the
entire cost of the device.
And they also come with apps
from user's favorite internet
services, including Google
Maps, Search, and, of course,
Google Assistant.
And the great news here is,
just like with Android Go,
your actions will be
available on these devices
with no extra work on your part.
Now, the user experience is
similar to a smart speaker,
so it's voice-only.
But for this new generation
of internet users
who are unburdened by the
habits and mental models
of graphic UIs, this is
an unbelievable chance
to generate confidence
in your service
by living on the Assistant.
So let me reiterate
the value here.
You build one action,
one common code base
in the cloud of your choice.
And your service
is going to live
across all of these devices,
for all of these users.
And with the Android or
smart speaker devices,
you can build for the complete
Actions on Google experience.
You can have users
sign into your service
and link their account.
You can even sell goods
in supported regions.
However, as we're just launching
for Android Go and KaiOS
devices, there will be some
limitations to consider.
So in particular, we won't
be supporting transactions
or account linking.
And KaiOS will only
support Actions
in Indian English and Hindi.
But we remain committed
to bringing feature parity
across these devices
going forward.
All right, so we know
what the next billion
users will be holding
in their hands
and what they'll be speaking to.
So now let's actually consider
what you can build for them.
If you want to get started
building great actions today,
build with Actions templates.
It's that simple.
We have a few different
varieties to choose from.
And if you already have
interesting content that you
want to get out there to users,
or you want to have some fun
and come up with something
new, templates give you
an out-of-the-box solution
to entering your content
into a Google sheet and
producing a high-quality Action
without writing a
single line of code.
In fact, all of you can
go home and do this today.
And the trivia quiz
and flash cards
templates work in 11
languages, including
the ones where we're seeing
growth amongst the next billion
users.
So this includes Spanish
localized to both Europe
and Latin America, as well as
Hindi, Brazilian Portuguese,
and Indonesian, with more
languages coming soon.
We've already seen success
with these use cases in regions
where the next billion users
are coming online, which is also
where entertainment and games
are a common use of technology.
So templates are a great
solution to use now.
Now, you might
remember the example
that Vlad gave earlier--
Cricbuzz.
They built an awesome cricket
quiz action using templates.
So I want to show
you how easy it
is to build something similar.
So all I did was I
created a project
at console.actions.google.com,
and I clicked Templates.
And it got me to this sheet.
So I literally just typed
in a bunch of questions
and some configuration
information,
like the difficulty levels
for all of those questions.
And then, boom, I've got
as good of an experience
as what Cricbuzz
was able to make.
And it's complete with
sound effects and error
cases handled.
You can go from 0 to
100 with templates.
And like I've said, we've
seen these do really well
with the next billion users.
So build one today.
Seriously, within hours, you can
have a production-ready action
to deploy
Now, if you're not looking
to build trivia quiz or flash
card solution, consider
building a conversation action.
So this gives you
complete control
of the dialogue with the
user, allowing you to express
your brand as you want.
And it creates a
frictionless way for users
to get things done,
learn about their world,
or have some fun
with your service.
Conversation Actions
are triggered by users.
They're usually done by
asking for you specifically
to the Assistant by name or just
saying what they want to do.
And from there, you go back
and forth with the user
until the action ends
the dialogue or the user
cancels out.
So what I have up
here is an example
of the action that was built
for this year's Google I/O.
And you can all try
this today if you have
the Assistant on your phones.
Just say, hey, Google,
talk to Google I/O '19.
So I encourage you
to try this one out.
Now, the question is, how do you
handle that complicated dialog
control and that natural
language understanding, or NLU?
So Dialogflow is
Google's answer.
And your action can be
backed by a Dialogflow agent,
including utilities
for matching everything
the user says throughout
the dialogue to intents.
This is done with
machine learning
and is trained by just
a few example phrases
that you provide.
Just 10 to 12 is enough.
And this also includes built-in
conversational modeling
for situations that
require repair,
like when the user
says something
that you don't recognize.
And all of this
can be customized
for different languages.
So for those of
you who are already
building conversation
actions, you're
probably already familiar.
But for anyone
new, you can learn
a lot more in our other
talks about Assistant.
Or you can jump in one of
our code labs here at I/O,
or maybe if you're
on the live stream
at home on your sofa at
codelabs.developers.google.com.
So I encourage you
to try that out.
Now, beyond the purely
conversational aspect
of these custom
conversational actions,
you can now leverage the
power of Interactive Canvas
to engage the next billion
users on their Android devices.
So this is how Chhota
Bheem was able to create
their visually impressive
and brand-consistent Kung Fu
Dhamaka Action.
And you can learn
more about this today.
There's a talk at
4:30, so check it out.
So let's say you are building
your own conversational
experience.
How should you
build it differently
for the next billion users?
Remember, conversational
interaction
is the first major technology
that, in the ideal,
assumes no prior knowledge on
the part of the user in terms
of understanding UI elements.
There's no need, for instance,
to understand a hamburger menu.
And this is especially
important for the next billion
users, some of whom
haven't learned this
and really shouldn't have to.
And I want you to
think about that
as we make our way through
the next few slides.
So firstly, a lot
of the same basics
apply for the next billion
as for the first billion.
And you can learn a lot more
about this in a talk tomorrow
at 2:30.
But the main takeaway
I want you all to have
here is that conversation
is new for everyone.
So consider these basics.
The first thing is,
consider your persona
ahead of time and draft
dialogues with it in mind.
Conversation is
inherently personal.
So express it
through your prompts.
Now, this doesn't mean you have
to stretch out your prompts
and shove a persona in there.
But use it when you're
considering the word
choice and the tone, et cetera.
Persona should be
based on your user
population, their local culture,
their jargon, their slang.
Consider it an
opportunity to build
a truly localized experience.
You'll also want to consider
context-sensitive repair.
So this means identifying all
the possible error conditions
throughout your dialogue when
a user might not understand
what's needed of them,
speech recognition errors,
and moving between
dialog pads unexpectedly.
And proactively build in
prompts to guide your user
to a productive state
in the dialogue.
So let me give you
a quick example.
In one of our samples that
we launched on GitHub,
we allow the user to hear facts
about either Google's history
or its headquarters.
So the question we ask
the user is, do you
want to hear about
history of headquarters?
Now, we expected the user
to say one of the two.
But sometimes they
would say yes or no,
because it's technically
a yes or no question.
So we changed the
prompt from "do
you want to hear facts
about this or that"
to "which do you
prefer," which changes
the question from a
confirmation question
to a disambiguation question.
So these are the kinds
of things to consider.
Now, I say error
conditions here.
But truly, in conversation,
there are no errors.
The user is attempting
cooperation.
So you need to repay that
with thorough dialogue design.
And then, when you're
supporting a screen device,
you can use that
to your advantage.
Remember, you can check
whether the device supports
screen output at runtime.
And you can use
this to determine
whether to present the user with
some visual selection options,
like suggestion chips,
or lists, or carousels.
Now, this is vital for
users around the world,
but especially for those
who might be unfamiliar
with conversational interfaces.
And then for devices that
rely less on visual output,
like smart feature phones
and smart speakers,
consider the full range
of the audible experience.
Utilize SSML, or a Speech
Synthesis Markup Language,
to create a richer experience
by adding custom audio
and marking up the TTS for
customized speech delivery.
All right, so we've covered the
basics of conversation design.
So let's talk about
some of the specifics
of designing your prompts
for the next billion users.
Now, the first thing is
you keep your prompts
short and to the point.
So except in the
case of gaming, users
are likely not looking for
long, drawn out interactions.
If the user is on
Android, you need
to prove that you can complete
the task faster than using
an app.
And if they're on a
smart feature phone,
that user is hostage to
your prompt until it ends.
So don't make them regret
invoking your action.
And the second
aspect of this is,
don't leave your prompts
open to interpretation.
Reduce ambiguity and user
frustration with short
prompts that ask for exactly
what you need the user to say
to progress in the dialog.
So one example from
Where Is My Train
is that they taper their
greeting for return
users with a shortened prompt.
And this is actually a
general best practice.
And we have utilities
built into the platform
for saving information about
the user across dialogs.
And they use the
information they already
have about the user
here to suggest
the next turn of dialogue.
And they give an explicit
yes-no question to progress.
Now, another tip for users
who might be unfamiliar
with smart assistive experiences
is to give them a handhold
into the conversation.
Prompt them
proactively, get to know
them and their preferences,
and surface the right behavior
from your action accordingly.
Leaving your prompts open-ended
and relying on the user
to find the functionality
that they need,
it can be frustrating.
And it's a missed opportunity
to intelligently engage.
So keeping your prompts
short and to the point
and proactively
understanding the user
increases the likelihood
of matching your Dialogflow
agent's training phrases and
providing a better experience.
All right, so speaking
of training phrases,
let's talk about how to
design your Dialogflow agent
or other natural language
understanding solution
to handle the next
billion users' languages.
Last year at Google for
India, we talked about some
of the really powerful
features we're
working on to understand the
way that your users will speak.
And this includes
understanding, for instance,
both Hindi and English
for a single user.
And you all can leverage
these investments
in speech recognition
in your actions as well.
So one scenario to consider
is mixed-language use,
or code switching, in
a single utterance.
It turns out this is a
pretty common phenomenon
in non-English
languages, especially
amongst bilingual users.
So let's look at an
example of this in Hindi.
So in Hindi, one way to ask for
the time is "kitne baje hai."
Forgive my pronunciation,
I'm still learning.
But you can also say "kya time
hua hai" or "kya time hua."
Now, here the user is literally
introducing the English word
"time" in their utterance.
So how does this get
handled in your action?
Normally, when you're
handling Hindi input,
you can expect
Devanagari script.
And the same happens
to be true here.
The word "time" gets
transliterated into Hindi
and passed through using
the same characters.
Your Dialogflow agent will
receive these characters.
And you can include them in
your intent-training phrases.
But what about proper
nouns or other words?
Let's look at another example.
So imagine the
user asks "what is
the GDP of India," or "bhaarat
kee geedeepee kya hai."
Now, in this case, "GDP"
gets transliterated
into the literal
sounds of "geedeepee."
And every user
speaks differently.
And they're always going
to choose different words
and phrases.
And we might understand
them differently.
So this is why it's
really important
to actually test your action
with users in the real world
and understand how
they say things,
and to keep an eye
on your Dialogflow
logs and your
analytics to see how
users are expressing themselves
when they're using your action.
But there are
exceptions to this.
So typed input and
suggestion chip content
will be passed through as is.
And the other thing
to keep in mind
is, your actions output, or
TTS, can use multiple languages
in certain cases.
So this means you
can better mirror
the user's natural
mixed language
use in the action itself.
So let's see how Hello
English handles code switching
in their action for learning
languages-- for learning
English, excuse me.
So in Dialogflow, you train a
natural language understanding
module by supplying
training phrases
for all of the intents
or turns of dialogue
in your conversation.
So the training phrases
provide examples
of what your user might
say when they're actually
expressing that intent.
And Dialogflow uses
machine learning
to match what users
say in real time
throughout the dialogue to the
example phrases you provided.
So let's look at the Choose
Lesson intent in Hello English.
So this is the intent that
gets triggered in the dialogue
when they're choosing
from a series of lessons
that they want to do.
And Hello English
offers a few ways
to select a lesson
for Hindi users.
So one way is to
speak Hindi out loud.
And they've covered that with
the bottom three training
phrases.
So in there, they
cover a couple of ways
to say the word
"lesson," including
the word "paath" in Hindi, as
well as the transliteration
of the English word "lesson."
But you'll also notice
the English word
for lesson in Latin
characters right
in their training phrases.
So why is this?
It's because their suggestion
chips use English text
to further help their
students learn the language.
And suggestion chip text is
passed directly to Dialogflow
as is.
So when it's selected, it
should match this intent.
So they have to include it
in their training phrases.
All right, so now we've
talked about trying
to cover all your
bases when it comes
to training your natural
language understanding module.
But you should still plan
for unexpected situations.
So as you might remember,
Vlad mentioned earlier,
we really invested heavily
and made significant progress
in automatic speech recognition.
But it may still be weak
on some of these devices
with hardware constraints.
And with different accents,
and different dialects,
and different levels
of technology exposure,
users are likely to
cause false positives
in speech recognition.
And on top of that, it's
important to anticipate
the context of your user.
Maybe they're in a
noisy environment,
and you can't expect
perfect speech recognition.
So let's see how
Hello English, again,
handled a case like this.
So again, taking us back to
the example from earlier,
in their Choose
Lesson intent, you'll
notice I've drawn attention
to a new training phrase--
and this is the Hindi
word for garlic,
"lahasun"-- because it
sounds similar to "lesson."
And this means that
their Dialogflow agent
is prepared to handle
the Hindi transliteration
of "lesson" and the speech
recognition mismatch
for "lahasun."
Now, one of the
last points I want
to make when it comes
to building a great user
experience is that you should
really consider smart feature
phones separately.
This is a new product segment
with its own user experience
and user needs.
And as I mentioned, there will
be some limitations at launch,
like account linking and
physical transactions.
But there are still
opportunities for your action,
like having your
directory page living
in RSS directory specially
designed for these phones.
And we'll be supporting smart
feature phones in the Actions
console simulator since testing
on device won't be supported.
Now, when it comes to
the user experience,
you can think of the smart
feature phone experience
as similar to a smart
speaker experience,
except that it's on-the-go
and accessible anywhere.
Now, because of that,
like I mentioned earlier,
you want to keep things short.
People don't want to
listen to long prompts.
And they need to know exactly
what to say afterwards
to reduce friction.
But also like I said
earlier, this also
means if you've built for a
voice-only experience in Indian
English or Hindi,
your Action is going
to be living on
these KaiOS devices
at no extra cost to you.
And like with all actions,
there is no installation,
meaning users
don't have to worry
about space limitations on these
phones to download your app.
And similar to a smart speaker,
the smart feature phone
experience is voice-only.
Keyboard input won't work.
And anyway, the keyboard
experience on these phones
isn't always as flexible
as touchscreen smartphones.
In fact, many users prefer
voice input and even
video calling to texting.
So this means you should
tailor your expected input
to voiceable queries.
So for instance,
let's say you're
building an action
against an API
that takes a postcode to pull
some information about a city.
Rather than expecting
this data directly
from the user in
the form of a number
value subject to all sorts
of speech recognition issues,
introduce a layer of abstraction
by asking for the city
directly and doing the
reverse geocoding on your end.
Or ideally, get an API
that accepts a city name.
And another example, this
is Where Is My Train.
So it turns out
train numbers can
be pretty hard to
remember and to speak out.
So they handle input by either
the train number or the train
name.
So for example, the Hyderabad
express for train 12603.
All right, we've talked a
lot about design and dialogue
considerations to make when
building for the next billion
users.
But now let's talk about
creating localized experiences
in your users' language.
Now, there are three touchpoints
for you to make these changes--
the Actions console, Dialogflow,
and in your fulfillment logic.
And the great thing is we've
already localized Actions
on Google in some of the main
countries where Assistant
is seeing heavy traffic,
particularly Hindi and Indian
English in India,
Brazilian Portuguese,
Latin American Spanish, as well
as Spanish as spoken in Spain,
and Indonesian.
Now, for the first touchpoint
in the Actions console--
again, at
console.actions.google.com.
And by the way,
this is where you
can get an overview
of your project
and even try it out in
different languages.
You can click the Languages
tab under Settings
to select all the languages
that you want to support.
And the other option you
have in the Actions console
is released targeting.
So this is where you
can select or limit
the countries in which
you want users to be
able to invoke your actions.
So suppose your service
only makes sense
in Mexico because it provides
local information to users
there.
Well, then you can
just target Mexico.
Or maybe it makes sense
only in a few countries.
In that case, we
support launching
in any subset of the countries
where Actions on Google
is available.
Now, the next step is to
update your Dialogflow agent.
So there's a few parts to this.
The first thing to recognize
is that all of your intents
remain the same between
your supported languages.
So you don't have to reconstruct
your dialog in each language.
However, you do need
to train Dialogflow
for the different
types of phrases people
may speak in the different
languages that you choose.
And this includes the
entities you support.
So for instance, if you're
writing an agriculture action,
and in English, you can listen
for different fruit types,
like "apples and bananas,"
you'll need to translate these
expected values in your
Spanish-speaking model,
so "manzanas y pltanos."
Now let's talk about
how we actually
do this in our back-end logic.
So let's suppose your
Actions persona was
a friend in your neighborhood
who can help you fix appliances
in your house.
Or for this example,
by the way, I'll
be using Node.js
with our Actions
on Google client library.
And I'm going to be deploying
to Cloud Functions for Firebase.
But you can write
your fulfillment code
in any language of
your choice, deploy it
on any infrastructure
you might choose--
Google Cloud or not.
There are no requirements.
But if you are using
Node, let's pretend
that you have the response
prompts for your action,
so that is the actual output for
your user, stored in some JSON
files.
And you can create
one for each language.
So the very simple
example I have here, I
have a greeting prompt
and a response for when
the user needs help.
And it's localized
for users in English
as well as Latin American
Spanish, or es-419,
and European Spanish.
And the main difference
between the Spanish locales
are the words for
computer and television.
Now, the response is keyed by
the type of the response, so
greeting, for instance.
And the value is the
response string itself.
And these kinds of files
make it really easy
to manage all of your
prompts and localization data
separately from
your webhook logic.
And there are even
translation services out there
that can help you localize your
prompts to different languages.
All right, so then let's
suppose I'm actually
writing out my JavaScript code
in a file called index.js.
The first thing
I'm going to do is
I'm going to import a library
for internationalization.
And in this case,
I'm using i18n-node,
which is available on NPM.
But there are plenty of
libraries available out there
for most of the programming
languages that you might use.
And many of them
have similar features
to what I'll be showing here.
So here what I'll do is
I'll configure the module
so that it knows where my
localized responses are.
So I'm keeping them in a
directory called locales.
And in this case,
I'm also configuring
it to fall back to
my Latin American
prompts for users in Mexico
and in the United States.
Because maybe these
prompts didn't
need special localization
for those users.
And then finally, I've
got a utility function.
It's called setLocale.
And it allows me to
change the locale
I want to use at runtime.
All right, so let's see
how I'm going to use that
later on in my webhook logic.
Now, when you're building
an action using Node.js,
again, we recommend
using our Actions
on Google client library.
It's available on NPM.
I have the command there.
And if you want to understand
how to use it better,
I highly recommend checking out
our other samples on GitHub.
We have a variety
of samples there.
We also have a
library in Kotlin.
And you can find samples that
use Java on GitHub as well.
But here, I'm importing
this client library
module for Node.js.
And I'm using it based on
a Dialogflow configuration.
And I'm initializing it here.
And then I'm going to
write some middleware which
calls the setLocale function
that we wrote earlier.
And this runs for every turn
of dialogue that gets handled.
So right before we
respond to the user,
we tell the i18n module
which language or locale
the current user is speaking in.
And then finally, when you're
responding to the user,
I can use the i18n dot
underscore underscore function
to pull the response from the
appropriate JSON file based
on the key designated there.
So again, just to recap,
the key steps are,
one, create localized versions
of your prompt strings
and encapsulate them somewhere
separate from your application
logic, two, configure
your i18n module
for any fallbacks you need
or any other configuration,
and three, read your prompt
strings from these JSON
files at runtime using
some unique identifiers.
And then the last
thing you'll want
to do after you've implemented
and tested your localized
action using our
web simulator is
you'll want to create a
localized directory entry.
So all of the available
third-party actions
on our platform, they live
in the Assistant directory.
And this is available online at
assistant.google.com/explore,
but also on the Assistant app
on all of the devices that
we've talked about here today.
And so for each
language you support
you can add different
information that'll
show up there, including
the description,
any branding images, and
even the privacy policy.
And that's it.
That's all you need to do to
create a localized experience.
Now, again, I recommend
starting with templates.
We've seen actions
that use templates.
They do really well.
And it's a great starting point
in understanding our platform.
But you can create
these highly customized
experiences yourself as well.
Now, I want to close by talking
about the opportunity here.
Actions on Google
is the platform
for reaching the
next billion users.
It enables you to
reach all of your users
on the devices that they use,
including smart feature phones,
in the interaction paradigm
that works for them.
For some of these
users, it'll be
their first time
interacting with your brand
or your service.
So make a great
first impression.
Users in emerging markets are
adopting voice and conversation
quickly.
That's why it's so
important to jump in now.
You all have the local
insights and understanding
to build the services
that these users need.
And we want to get you there.
So build actions supporting the
devices connecting these users
today, and design
your experiences
to engage with their
world on their terms.
Now, you can visit
developers.googl
e.com/actions/templates to
learn more about templates.
You can also check out our
localization documentation
there as well as our number
genie sample in both Node.js
and Java on GitHub.
And then finally, I highly
recommend that you check out
the documentation we have on
the different devices that
we've discussed here
today at developers.googl
e.com/actions/nbu.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]